[Music]
howdy-ho reject nation it's Greg Alda
here
jonald we are going to do something
awesome David Gandy one of our top
patrons dear friend also as well he came
to our live event and we had breakfast
than the next day I love that man he had
a unique video request something very
him and I tend to have long messages
back and forth and he was telling me
I've says was for a reason he was
telling me how he got that one of those
DNA tests you know were you like submit
stuff and then few weeks later you uh
you know get your results back and you
find out if you're 1% African American
or not or not African American but
African descent Native American yeah
yeah yeah you know those are the
counting on both for me those are the
ones that everyone close out about
always the ones that people flip out
about I think this is the package he
says today's date right now Friday the
9th let me just just the boyhood of
unboxing because yeah let's let's see
here if this is any up it's Andy's DNA
test kit here this is a Google branded
DNA test that's one of those ones you do
is do yourself and then you then you
mail it in or something like that and
then you you get the oh cool saliva you
don't even have to like bleed all over
it or pee on it or anything I was gonna
do both well you still can do you want
to pee on it no all right let's see what
we got here
yeah how do you open this I don't like
to read instructions you're getting
further than I am okay so let's see
saliva collection kit whew interesting
hey let's get started let's get started
we were excited for you to begin this
journey and we want you to know we're
here to help whether it's quick
questions or about our service how'd I
get started we have resources available
to help you
resources share your experience and it's
even postmarked so we can send it right
back that's cool no trouble to share the
discovery 30% off one kit for a friend
or family member I know what I'm getting
family members dude I'll get my siblings
maybe you've got all the Native American
weird things happen with genetics I
supposed registered this kit now at
23andme dot-com / start no food or drink
for 30 minutes all right we got the way
a little bit
I definitely add something to drink a
little bit yeah does this mean that
we're supposed to brush our teeth first
or table reading there's no no brushing
of teeth spit - okay spit - fill line
detach funnel screw on cap seal in
bagged mail and kiddo is that it's
pretty self-explanatory
yeah you just spit in it alright yes
send it off alright then we'll continue
this in 30 minutes
exactly yeah alright so it's been about
45 minutes we have registered everything
I agreed to bio banking John did not
save my DNA yeah you don't know what
they're gonna do with it I didn't have
any chance to read any of that's why
they make things so long so you just say
yes and then get swamped with email fill
line spit to fill the line okay so we're
spitting into this section right here
yeah you spit down this funnel here and
then it collects in this little part
down here when you gotta fill it up to
this fill line it's not just gonna go
through the other end no there's a
little stopper right here on the dotted
line
it looks like you're gonna fill up like
it really it's only just like a smidge
that's so gross disgusting thing is I
don't have much pent-up saliva yeah they
said don't drink damn we got Philip that
much actually this is a lot this is
surprisingly hard look how much is here
yeah I feel that much spit it is not
easy that is not easy I can't tell if
it's the spit or the funnel but neither
one is entirely healthy like I'm making
no progress on us so gross I'm gonna
throw up
the collection of spit oh God
oh yeah I see a bunch of saliva in one
place is a little icky I'd rather pee in
this station no I can't do urinary
samples at lab tests and stuff otherwise
so girls got peter cuppin pay you five
bucks a drink my spit yeah I won't take
five for that I'll take a certain amount
yeah no oh god you paid me enough
sterile or at least if you're healthy um
as a process mm-hmm a whole bunch of
time you got like suck stuff out of your
salivary glands it's amazing alright
time-lapse video don't look there's so
much grosser time doing this next to you
alright this is the the strangest
bondings the amount of spit on my
girlfriend I could have just put it in
this tube should have said drink a lot
of water morning and then starts
[Music]
jeez John you like [ __ ] over spit
well mine's frothier than yours and I
don't know if those are just bubbles
that are gonna you know dissipate later
so I'm like I got to make sure fresh
spittle this is gross David it's not
worth lying on my DNA yeah yeah
all right well wait for the results and
finish this video what do you think our
ethnicity just got back from the gym and
come to find out our results are in it's
November 23rd we submitted our spit on
November 10 and we have pulled up there
are reports we have not looked at them
which is a way that you have to click it
or go to view them it's gotta be a
reaction I'm gonna finally find out I
always tell people Italian or Filipino
you're only two I'm gonna start out with
my genetic health risks yeah you got 916
relatives - damn do you have 978 my
family is big ancestry here we go pie
chart here Filipino and US Austronesian
a lot of things
40% Phillip a 2% 2.3 percent Indonesian
Thai Wow no wonder everyone loves our
raid reaction yeah
Oh 0.1% Native American now you gotta
take that in Oh put a ridiculous amount
of pride oh yeah I found out I'm 0.1%
Native American action pick a random
drive and claim that one is my own I'm
primarily East Asian Native American it
says here damn [ __ ] yeah broadly Chinese
Southeast Asians 6.0% Raleigh northern
Asian and Native American 0.4% Wow okay
I don't know a lot of that means
whatever
you know map here okay
I am a little confused by how you can be
broadly Asian but also Native American
in the same category 27.5% european
italian only 16% of salt 50 this whole
time that's a message disappointment
Iberian oh interesting oh you can click
on them to find out ooh I can see that
latin-american awesome southern European
Italian okay so yeah there are eight
point one percent 0.2 percent nor what
how do you I got some European me a lot
of a lot of Asian okay and Oh 0.4
percent North African yeah you go I got
the coolest ones and broadly Western
Asian in North African 3.0% 0.5%
sub-saharan African my brother's hell
yeah I'm at least 1% African celebrate
your true heritage this is so cool show
up the next video in like a dashiki and
like some kind of traditional asian
robes or whatever just like all decks
from all your different places of work
undecide 4.9% there's almost a 5 percent
part of me that is mysterious yeah
that's from like the Antarctic an area
51 in all those places that aren't
actual countries Wow
alright well let's let's let's do yours
oh here we go go for us go to your
ancestor John time let's see let's see
let's see I'm excited to get a lot of
white 60% full of Peter is literally
like a no brainer Oh 30 percent British
and Irish the United Kingdom
shirt checks out yes Eastern European
yeah yeah this is always told that I had
some like you know Slovaks and like
Czechoslovakian roots in there I'm
surprised the French and Germans bigger
than Italian for how Italian my
grandma's family is okay French and
German 15.7% Italian 5.3% who Balkan
despite broad cultural diversity Balkan
people are genetically similar to one
another well I would assume descending
from early Mediterranean Slavic
ancestors interesting okay and then the
rest is broad I have broadly southern
European 10% broadly Northwestern
European nine point a present and then
broadly European I feel like my
breakdown said okay well here are the
specifics we know here's Britain Ireland
everybody France and Italy like
everything you are and if we missed any
European countries specifically we're
just gonna lump them all together and a
bunch of other disparate categorize so
far like a smidgen of a North American
ativ American or an Africa or anything
like that minds like this like super as
complicated I am insanely ethnically
diverse it allowed to be kinda bummed
out or should I just take Friday this is
everything you've always said you are
you know it was an accurate depiction my
folks gave me
I mean we're gonna look through all
these other things and submit more
information but it's pretty cool to know
my exact details are I am primarily more
my mom's DNA got in me than my dad
that's fascinating my dad has no agent
only European Italian yeah man from all
over the world yeah and I am from this
little my DNA is all over the world
yeah that's pretty crazy so for
Australia missed out wow I guess it
would vary then from like siblings yeah
yeah I mean cuz there's dominant and
recessive genes and who gets what is
always kind of a genetic crapshoot yeah
my dad spit on my mom during that if you
spit on her that would that would that
would change your genetic app because
soaked into her pores and fuses with the
right accounts that egg and that saliva
damn this has changed my whole mindset
of me I've always thought I was a solid
5050 hey man look at you now you still
got a fair amount of that
that Europe in yeah barely good old 27
and a half percent it's a little more
than a half of you know your Asian side
it's still majority kind of it away
whatever John Doe proud of it good
Filipinos for life and Indonesians and
ties and go visit each one of them but
go claim your roots this was fun
well thank you David Andy no appreciate
it is crazy this is eye-opening heritage
yeah this is this is mind-boggling to me
yeah that's so much for you yeah no just
a good confirmation of what I was
already certain about I'm so at me it's
kind of crazy do you feel more ethnic
than when you sat down to read these
yeah all right guys well thank you David
share your results with us this is this
is weird
Wow there's more of a reaction out of me
than I expected
more like everything I hope he's known
it's not your mole identity has changed
my whole life is any minute culturally
it's Italian if Filipino better than
that my whole world wouldn't flipped
upside down all that spit and you found
this out just to think we sat there in
spat for like five straight minutes to
learn this information all right well
subscribe and I guess I'm moving to the
Philippines now and I'm white
you